traición abuso de poder y representación
de una organización no oficial estos
fueron los argumentos que dio la junta
militar para cesar al embajador de
mianmar ante la onu ya un montón un día
antes ante la onu levantó los tres dedos
el símbolo que se ha tomado las
protestas instó a la comunidad
internacional a ayudar a restaurar la
democracia y arengó a los manifestantes
a revertir el golpe de estado
de turgua les pido que continúen debemos
triunfar y el pueblo es lo más
importante nuestra misión debe cumplirse
lucha llegan los manifestantes
obedecieron y miles de personas
volvieron a las calles de mi alma
los manifestantes obtuvimos mucho
aliento para protestar después de ver a
nuestro embajador ante la onu lo que
tampoco faltó este sábado fue la
represión policial testigos aseguran que
fue la jornada más violenta en tres
semanas según la asociación de
asistencia para prisioneros políticos
cientos de personas fueron detenidas
también hubo gas y fuego real
las protestas y la presión internacional
tratan de revertir el golpe de estado
del 1 de febrero por parte de la junta
militar sin embargo el viernes la nueva
comisión electoral anuló los resultados
de los comicios de noviembre en los que
el partido liga nacional para la
democracia de aung san suu kyi había
arrasado precisamente existe
incertidumbre por el paradero de su chip
después de que la premio nobel de la paz
haya pasado a estar en arresto
domiciliario se le acusa de haber
importado ilegalmente 6 radio
walkie-talkie y de violar una ley de
desastres naturales al quebrantar los
protocolos de la gestión del coronavirus